well BBC reporter Laura trevillian whose
ancestors kept slaves in Grenada says
her family hopes to set an example by
handing over a hundred thousand pounds
in reparations to their descendants
meanwhile San Francisco panel studying
reparations has proposed a five million
dollar payment to every black resident
of the city to compensate them the
historic harm well that proposal is
being discussed publicly today is this a
sensible way of writing historic evils
or is it actually just sowing more
divisible joining me in the studios talk
to the contributor Esther crack who
wrote a very striking article for the
Daily Mail about this today alongside
columnist and author Matthew said and
talk TV contributor Paula Roan Asia
welcome to all of you Esther I loved
your piece today thank you uh because it
to me this is all a bit ridiculous
the idea that somehow it's going to make
any tangible difference to start dotting
out hundreds of thousands millions of
pounds Dollars around the world to
people who had descendants involved in
slavery yeah I think is I think it's
woke virtue signaling gone nuts yeah I
mean I think it's it's an obsession with
white liberals to publicly spit spit
shine their Halos But the irony is you
know the money that her family received
um in conversation of getting rid of
these slaves but in today's money three
million pounds so actually a hundred
thousand pounds it's not really scratch
it's not even 10 of what they receive
that's the first point and also once you
start going down that route there's so
many ways you can sort of skin this cat
so if you have a mixed race person with
a black father who was uh descendant of
slaves and a white mother who is
descendant of slavers who pays
reparations does that mixed race person
have to pay I mean there's so many ways
to to and in the case of that BBC
journalist her family were also
responsible for pretty ugly behavior in
Ireland yes exactly what happens there
well there's been you've said nothing
about that right and I thought people on
Twitter say who are Jewish say well what
happens to us then yeah right so in
other words once you start the the
concept and I'll bring in Matthew once
you start this concept of reparations
for historic ills where does it end and
who do you include and who did you leave
out I think that that's the part I have
no problem with an individual deciding
they want to give their money to
reparations or any other charitable
cause of their wish that the problem
comes when the state
decides to use public money that will be
hugely divisive it may sound good to
some people particularly on the left on
the Progressive left in condoned
discrimination even though because
that's what we're talking about
for the following reason once you start
as as you I think rightly pointed out
once you start specifying the criteria
under which the money is given out it
will create huge controversy and
Division and of course it raises in the
same way that racism has well I I speak
as somebody who's mixed race my father
was born in India my mother is Welsh the
question I've got for you you're in
favor of reparations is as a country
that was colonized should I discuss as
an ancestor or something let him ask the
question now would in your in your
analysis should I be the beneficiary of
reparations as somebody whose father
grew up in the British Empire right I
don't know
no Civic scenario so I couldn't possibly
answer that question you should have
that right what I can add to this
discount I can add to this discussion be
specific then so my father was born in
Hyderabad the south of India he moved to
Pakistan after partition property was
effectively confiscated and then came to
Britain to study law uh I'm his son I
may have been wealthier had that not
happened okay so I can give you more
details is there a case this Unity
should be there for that land to be
returned to your family I think in the
same way that we had the Marshalls
same way that we've had the Marshall
Plan in the same way that the slave
owners were paid for the loss of their
sleep what about the people
only just the British government has
only just finished paying that debt off
um in 2015. in the same way the American
government took responsibility and and
made reparations to the Native American
Paula how is it how is he going to help
Japanese who were interned during World
War Two you but but you can say okay
okay but this is what we're talking
about there are very well I've noticed
the question poignant example so where
reparations was right and which you
wouldn't deny whether how can it be
right for a place like San Francisco
just to even have the concept of giving
Millions out to all the residents who
happen to be black how can that make any
difference how can that improve Racial
equality in that City it can't you can
only have your lab effects you can only
bring in deeply
if I answer the question what they're
doing is they're discussing it in the
same way that we are now what they are
doing is they are looking at the stats
and in America what we understand is
that uh white people are ten times uh
more socio socioeconomically in a
positive position than those of color
they know that and so what they're doing
is they're looking at the situation and
they're saying how can we make
how can we make the playing field the
color of Asian
why the government should be empowered
to to take this on a case-by-case basis
and skin this cat in as many ways as
they want people decide who should be
the beneficiary why do they have the
right to do that it will tear Western
societies
if I may just finish the the one if we
we need to get to a situation
which Martin Luther King articulated
brilliantly in the mid-60s where people
are judged on the content of their
character rather than the pigmentation
of their skin a level Place
well as as you might be pointed out
white working-class people in this
country are some of the poorest
demographics how are they going to feel
about richer descendants of black
Africans getting reparations
I haven't had the opportunity I'm the
same way that the others have I have a
wider Point generally which is about
this this sort of constant drum beat now
to make people atone for the sins of
centuries ago I think it is completely
regressive to do this we've surely got
to move in the way Society has moved
there isn't slavery anything like the
way there was hundreds of years ago how
has Society moved in terms of that Level
Playing Field how is it right that the
slave owner Miss receives reparation but
the slaves don't well this is the thing
do you know how you run because people
can read your competition
anymore they're not only finish the
British government only finished paying
for that in 2015. why is nobody
uncomfortable about that why is nobody
okay it's about commercials
well-educated wealthy lawyer yeah
absolutely and you'll follow up here
fortunately Super Rich what right I'm
not I'm not super rich but I am full but
you're very grateful for that and you're
certainly more fortunate than I did
Growing Up how well sorry what are you
talking about what do you know about me
what right do you know let's all go over
each other yes
privileged as a privileged wealthy
well-educated woman what right do you
have for reparations for something that
you never experienced I can't even claim
that no one can claim but Esther I have
just said to you I don't think I would
have a claim and there are many people
who wouldn't have a crime but that
doesn't mean because I don't have an
opportunity that I I shouldn't stop
others from happening I would have said
that to a Native American
yes
what about Black Americans who are the
descendants of slaves who are now
billionaires
what about them well would they be
eligible for your reparations it's not
my reparations
it's my conversation about people having
the opportunity to do you think they
should get it do I they probably not
also be means tested it could possibly
be yeah and who should be it there are
options
discussion and that's exactly what's
happening at the moment there's a
discussion that's ongoing about how it's
going to happen and how it is the same
way that you would have a discussion
positive discrimination
about leveling the playing field some
stage that's a discussion where someone
can actually discuss something with you
which involves you stopping talking for
a second I have a strong view about this
that none of it seems right to me that
making people pay today for the sins of
centuries ago I think is completely
ridiculous and I think what kind of
society particularly the cost of living
crisis
something is dishing out billions in in
reparations to people who had no
personal experience the British
government had to take a loan out to pay
the slave owners do we get that money
back because we the complete the
government get that money back what do
you think Martin Luther King would say
let me ask you a question I mean when I
asked the question no one wants to
answer this I'm asking you a question
let me ask you a question first for the
loss of their slave 1837 and the
government only finished paying it off
in 2015. should the British government
get that money back look I have a
different question for you which is this
which is this what would Martin Luther
King say if he was still with us about
this concept
I don't know he would think it's
ridiculous what do you think he would
say he was a man who wanted Unity right
he wanted unity and this will be the
most divisive thing that I don't want
Unity suggesting that it's devices in
the 1960s
the Nation of Islam run by Elijah
Muhammad Malcolm X Muhammad Ali they
wanted a separate Homeland for black
Americans within the borders of the
United States they were completely
against the integrationist agenda of
Martin Luther King and had they won that
argument it would have been the most
retrograde step for America and the West
this is going down precisely the same
trajectory it is going to stir racial
division it will destroy the fabric of
the United States we've got to get and
in the meantime those who haven't been
able to overcome those who have been
held back you are saying to them quiet
no I'm saying let's create a fairer
Society okay so how do we do that
Matthew well that is
is what politics is all about make an
argument for Parliament that's tomorrow
night's show how do you make Society a
better place uh really it's a really
interesting debate honestly it is it's a
very good debate and I'm not sure what
the answer is I just don't think the
answer is shelling out billions to
people who had no personal experiences
for slavery because I don't see how that
helps anything frankly and I think the
point is is that that personal
experience lives on I think for those
who argue about reparation okay the
difficulty I've given you the final word
because that's the kind of guy thank you